what we're going to look at today is to
extend this story about stacks and
reverse polish a little bit further many
of you said oh yeah I learned about
postfix reverse polish when I had an HP
calculator and in those comments you've
helped to answer some of the questions
that other commenters have said well why
would you ever use reverse polish it
does your head in as the saying goes do
people really have to think like that
why do calculator manufacturers and why
do the inventors of the PostScript
language force it on us and the answer
is very simple
it makes underpowered machinery a lot
easier to work well if the machinery
makes you do all the hard work of
converting infix which you're much more
comfortable with into reverse polish and
it doesn't have to do that job that's
why relatively low-powered calculators
could do so much and it's why looking
back at my other video about the desktop
publishing revolution at the end of that
I tried to make clear that the
PostScript interpreter was running on
underpowered hardware and one of the
reasons it could succeed in doing that
is again it makes you do all the hard
work I think it's interesting its own
right and it's also interesting when
you're trying to delve a little bit more
into compilers interpreters and computer
science general principles because under
the hood these kind of issues about
stacks and trees are utterly utterly
foundational in the whole of our subject
today I want to get in properly into
trees and show you how fundamental they
are and an ideal way to do it is to pick
up from the end of my stacks and reverse
polish video which you might want to
look at first if you haven't already
pick up from where we left off and say
what's the fundamental story behind all
of this and the answer is it's the tree
shape I started off by writing down the
arithmetic expression A plus B
multiplied by sin
if you accept the multiplied must be
done first then the reverse polish
notation it would of course be a B C
Star Plus remember our PN reverse polish
you can call it postfix also if you want
to fair enough that somehow you've got
to know which of the high priority
operators in which of the low priority
operators in other words which ones get
done first and multiply and divide are
of the same precedence as each other
they're high precedence they get done
first but what happens if you've got a
string of the stuff all of which
involves exactly the same operator do
you do it
left to right or right to left does it
matter
let's take a very very simple case 27 +
9 + the range should it be add nine to
27 first and then add three or should it
be keep the 27 and add it to what you
get when you do the 9 + 3 addition first
this is called left Association this one
of course is called right associativity
or right Association and look with plus
as ever there's a very little problem so
it doesn't matter at all ah but here
comes the one where it massively matters
how about 27 divided by 9 divided by 3
do you do that and then that all your
group here
well the default is always the left
Association you go left to right try
this only calculator if you find that
that is exactly what it does
27 divided by 9 is 3 3 divided by 3
actually gives us an integer answer here
a 1 if you did it the other way of 27
divided by
9/3 the answer then would be nine the
ordering in which you do things is
twofold
first of all you do your high priority
things first and then if you've got
things of equal priority strung out in
front of you you do them left to right
it all comes down to trees back to the
beginning a plus B times C what diagram
could I draw that makes it happen
correctly in other words makes the
multiply be done first and the answer is
draw a tree draw yourself a tree house
ever it's computer scientists we all
know now computer scientist trees have
their route at the top and the leaves
down at the bottom here's a leaf the a
upper end and here down by the multiply
is the B and the C and you can very
easily see why that's the case
particularly if you think about this
whole thing as being driven by the
operands not the operators imagine that
the a is knocking on the door the plus C
go on add me to something and the plus
is kind of saying well I can't because
I've got to know what the right operand
is and I can't know what the right up
around is until it reports back to me
and says what the intermediate answer
from its expression is so again think of
the be interrupting the multiply
operator and say we ready we're ready
multiplies together so the multiplier
does its work and it then passes its
results up the tree to the plus that can
finally do the whole thing
so therefore if that's the shape for
that one what about the shape for this
one the thing that gets done last is the
operator at the top of the tree look the
different trees the reason that this
gets different reverse polish gets a
different answer even in the vast
majority of cases here is that the tree
shapes are different and once you've
said ah
so it's all down to the tree shape I
draw yes it is because here comes even
more hidden fat chick from the tree you
can work out what the forward polish and
that the reverse polish will be you
don't need to just pick it out of thin
air as I did last time start here you go
anti-clockwise walk around it
anti-clockwise as I start this walk I
keep looking to my left if I see an
operator can I write it down no you
can't you can't write down an operator
until you've seen all of its operands in
all their glory however as you walk
around here looking to the left all the
time
hug the tree shape as closely as you can
look to your left
what do you see you see the upper and a
you can always write down and up around
come round here hug the tree all the
time looking to your left up there look
you see the operator can you write it
down yet no you can't you've seen it's
left up around but you haven't seen it's
right up around so you still can't write
it down hug the tree look to your left
oh there's a new operator multiplying
can you write it down nope you haven't
seen its operands so you can't write it
down hug the tree keep looking to the
left you see the bee can you write it
down yes you can always write an opera
Mandor down round the corner still
hugging the tree see the multiply
looking to the left for the second time
still can't write it down you've seen
one operand you haven't seen the other
so ignore it for the moment look to the
left you see the sea you can write it
down nearly round the tree now come
around here remember always looking to
the left ah now you see the star can I
write it down yes because I've seen both
of its operands finally here are a big
take up at the top you look to the left
you see the plus can you write it down
yes you can because you've visited all
of its operand structure it's as simple
as that so if you've got the tree you've
got the postfix you might like to try
walking round the tree
wise and doing the same thing but by
looking to the right all the time as the
clockwise Traverse gives you forward
polish prefix in Reverse and just to do
your heading to be very clear that
forward polish in Reverse is not the
same as reverse polish which is that you
get the tree you can derive implicitly
or explicitly postfix for use internally
in working out your register usage or if
you're in an interpreter for
implementing execution on the stack
trees lead to reverse polish quite
automatically just by walking round them
in the correct way
if you get a choice of either that pair
or that pair of thirds
it doesn't matter wait the system works
look at that